you're an indie game developer
passionate about bringing your next
mobile game to life you know the quest
is not going to be easy but you are
ready to face any challenge in the
search for the elusive 5 star rating a
voyage that leads to a game that is
loved and played by many whether you are
crafting a brand new space adventure or
creating a role-playing game with
monsters and magic
we know that trying to rise to the top
can feel like a tough climb what if
there is a way to supercharge your game
introducing indie games accelerator by
google play a program to fast-track your
throw and give your game that with real
boost get direct coaching on game
development best practices from top
gaming experts and Google mentors attend
all-expenses save gaming boot camps at
Google Asia's headquarter in Singapore
where you'll learn everything about
building a successful gaming company
apply for the program today to give your
game the next level up